You've been sleeping your whole life and
you've been doing it wrong. That 8-hour
rule everyone swears by, the science
says it's a lie. Researchers tracked
over 500,000 people. The cognitive sweet
spot, 7 hours, not eight. Seven. But
here's what's genuinely unsettling. Too
much sleep is just as damaging as too
little. Brain scans prove it. Your brain
literally shrinks on both ends. And
here's what really got my attention.
While you're unconscious, your brain
isn't resting. It's running the most
sophisticated optimization program in
nature, consolidating memories at 20
times speed, literally rewiring neural
pathways. Sleep isn't downtime, it's
upgrade time. And the scary part, most
people have no idea what they're losing
every single